all right breaking just moments ago the
house oversight committee conducted a
transcribed interview with a former FBI
supervisory special agent assigned to
that FBI Wilmington office now the agent
confirmed key portions of the IRS
whistleblower's testimony including that
both Secret Service headquarters and the
Biden transition team were tipped off
about that planned Hunter Biden
interview joining us now this is
Blockbuster house Judiciary Committee
chair Jim Jordan house oversight
committee chairman James Comer
Congressman Comer uh This is Wild what
else can you tell us
well this confirmed key components of
what the Irish whistleblowers told the
Ways and Means Committee in a
transcribed interview and this is good
because many Democrats and many in the
liberal media have tried to discredit
the whistleblowers prior to the
Committee hearing that we're going to
have on Wednesday so these two
whistleblowers are going to come in
front of the American people in front of
the house oversight committee on
Wednesday for about six hours and the
American people are going to get to hear
the truth from two credible people on
the front lines that were in charge of
trying to find corruption within the IRS
and hear what this FBI agent confirmed
is they were blocked at every turn they
were tipped off the Secret Service
tipped off the Biden as as well as the
Biden transition team why would the
Biden transition team need to know that
the whistleblowers were about to
interview Hunter Biden so I think this
is good stuff and it adds credibility to
our whistleblowers
um Congressman Jordan we understand that
one of the whistleblowers is going to
reveal himself later this week or
herself later this week what do you
expect that will do to the Democrats
attempt to really smear this whole
process and I you you know they're going
to end up further smearing trying to
smear these individuals well these two
whistleblowers have been nothing but
credible and today with the FBI agent
confirming key parts of their testimony
that just gives more credibility this is
quickly coming down to Laura who are you
going to believe the Biden justice
department that said parents were
terrorists who said Catholics were
extremists who censored Americans first
amendment Free Speech rights or these
two whistleblowers who have impeccable
Records who got performance reviews
always outstanding who were the go-to
guys when it came to International tax
fraud cases these two guys were the
go-to team who are you going to believe
these two guys who've now been confirmed
by an FBI agent or the Biden Garland
justice department I think I'll Trust
the whistleblowers and I think you will
see that on Wednesday when they appear
in chairman Comer's committee oh
Congressman Comer I want to get your
reaction to this moment between Biden's
former press secretary and one of your
colleagues
How concerned are you of that James
Comer was the chairman of the committee
was knowingly unknowingly working with
co-opted by a foreign agent I'm just
concerned that
um the house oversight committee was
suddenly being compromised in a really
serious way our legitimacy is being
eroded by the tactics adopted by
chairman Comer
Congressman Comer your response sir
it's very disappointing but not
surprising the tactics that we are using
the house oversight committee is we're
using a thing called evidence and it's
something that Jamie are Askins has no
concept of and the Democrat liberal
media will not consider we have the
Biden's bank records we have Bank
violations from six different banks that
all reported to the treasury cabinet
that they felt like the Biden family was
laundering money through Shale companies
they were concerned about the fact that
some of these wires they were getting
from foreign Nationals were from
state-owned entities that means they're
from from the government from the
Chinese Communist party so I don't think
that Jamie you're asking or Jim saki can
point to one thing that we produce one
thing that we put on oversight
stationery that cannot be backed up by
facts in the form of hard evidence from
bank records and Bank violations for the
buying family
Congressman Jordan you sent a letter I
know today to Mark Zuckerberg yeah I
love this already which reads in part
given that maida has censored protected
speech as a result of government
agencies requests the committee is
concerned about potential First
Amendment violations that will occur on
the threads platform and according to
Fox Business you're strongly considering
holding Zuckerberg in contempt of
congress are you going to really move
forward on this is this is just a bunch
of us if he doesn't give us the
information we will threads threads is
using the same guidelines that Facebook
use we know Facebook was censoring
Americans because a federal court told
us so two weeks ago laid out 86 pages of
facts with Facebook and federal agencies
pressuring them and other big tech
companies so we want we don't want this
to be going on this is a direct attack
on the First Amendment and we want the
information we've asked for months ago
and if they don't give it to us we can
move ahead with uh contempt if we need
to
all right Congressman great to see you
both thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else